i was like you know what i'm in my 40s
like
sorry like just go for it find your
happiness yeah and like i went for it
and i took my time and i found it and it
feels so good and i want to hold on to
that forever yeah good
and it seems like forever may be in the
cards for kim kardashian and pete
davidson from the snl star branding her
name on his chest i just think he was
like i want something that's there that
i can't
you know get rid of my tattoos he's like
i don't want to be able to get rid of it
or to cover it up and i just wanted it
like there as like a scar
on me
it's so cute guys it is cute two making
their relationship ig official a source
tells e.t the lovebirds both want to
take their relationship to the next
level why not
the source says kim and pete who've been
dating since the fall are super serious
and enamored with each other now are you
gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the two are continuing to work on seeing
their relationship bloom further
regardless of the drama that kanye
previously created and speaking of the
drama with her estranged husband god
sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
after attacks in his music and those
social media rants there's no such thing
as 50 50 custody
with with in society today that's not
that's not even
it always leans towards the mom
e.t has learned kanye told kim he's
going to get help and has agreed to stop
cyber bullying pete and harassing her
our source says for the sake of kim and
kanye's four kids north saint chicago
and somme yey told kim he's not making
any public appearances or inflammatory
social media statements and he will go
away somewhere to get better just
just do something for my heart
yay's pr rep adds quote at this time yay
is committed to a healthy co-parenting
relationship with kim and is focusing on
raising their beautiful children he's
already pulled out of his next big event
headlining coachella i always saw such a
good example in my mom and my dad in
their relationship so i'm always just
hopeful
the former couple does seem to be
aligned on their parenting goals moving
forward at least judging by what kim
recently told ellen degeneres no matter
what goes on you know it's the father of
my kids i'll always be protective i
always
want my kids to just see the best of the
best
so i just try to as hard as it can be
sometimes i do try to ignore it and just
try to do whatever's best for the kids
that's what i love about you because
take the high road
yeah
and when times get tough pete will no
doubt be there for her i love that last
month kanye revealed text messages pete
sent him in response to yay's online
behavior thesaurus tells e.t pete spoke
out because it got to a point where he
personally felt like he had to stand up
for himself as a man and a protector he
is over the negativity that kanye
brought to him and kim and her family
the source adds the skim's founder is
also over the drama and is doing her
best to separate herself pete and her
family from it she is mostly concerned
about her kids being privy to hearing
about things and having to potentially
experience negativity by extension she
just wants everyone to move on be happy
and to co-parent in a healthy way
[Applause]
[Music]